>>Mark: The idea of making computer
game is, to a lot of people,
is probably quite an intimidating
or something they think
only geniuses can do.
It's just not true.
>>Kareem: Little Big Planet
is an all in one tool set.
>>James: While it ships
with a hundred levels,
you get to make your own levels using
exactly the same tools that we do.
>>John: It really appealed to me,
being able to build whatever
I could think of really.
>>James: Once you've made those
levels, you get to publish them
on the internet and you get to
share them with your friends
and with everyone else in the world.
>>James: And we have just
over six million levels
and games up there now.
>>Christophe: It's just
a platform for creation.
>>Alex: If you like,
it's a Lego crossed
with a YouTube crossed
with a platform game.
>>John: Most computer games
judge your skill or your ability
in the game based on how many kills
you've got or how fast you can get
around a track, which can
be judged by computer.
The only people who
can really judge levels
in Little Big Planet are
other real life human beings.
A computer can't say
if art is amazing
or not; only another human can.
>>Alex: We coined this phrase, "Play,
Create, Share," for the first game,
but we didn't actually
realize how true that was.
>>James: I think the only way you can
really learn from what you've made is
to see what other people think of it.
To go through that whole process
of people enjoying what you've made
but also judging what you've made.
>>Alex: What Media Molecule
provides is this idea of education
and mutual community support.
>>Christophe: Collaboration
is so essential.
You can create something really
good by yourself, in your cave.
But if you don't listen to any advice
and any critics, or you're like, "Ha,
ha, I don't care about those
guys who don't like my levels,"
you will never learn,
you will never progress.
>>Alex: We realized that it was
that cycle of showing something off
that really motivated
and allowed people
who didn't consider
themselves creative
to totally get motivated
and make stuff.
>>Christophe: When you play
together, when you create together,
I made something and my colleague
takes it and improves it.
And then I get it back and it's
like, "Wow, that's really nice."
And then, "Ah, that
gives me another idea."
>>James: Some people are
artists, some people are more
like programmers, some
people make music.
>>Kenneth: People who kind of
adopt, they kind of wear the hat
of the educator and they take great
pleasure in explaining to other users
in the community how stuff works.
So they'll build a level which
is effectively a tutorial.
>>Kengo: They learn something, think
"Hey, this is amazing," and then want
to learn, just pass
on that knowledge.
And I think that's something
very inherently human really.
>>Alex: And you learn so much
from seeing what masters have done
and being able to take it apart
and put it back together again.
>>James: The more that we enable
people to create stuff together,
the more kind of an explosion
of creativity we get,
that we could never have anticipated.
>>Alex: The most satisfying thing
with me, with Little Big Planet is,
at its core, it's quite simple,
but I've seen people use it in ways
that I could never have imagined.
>>Kareem: Personal
expression I think is one
of those things that will never go.
Everybody has a story to tell
and that's a very human thing.
>>James: Showing people
that they can,
if they're given the right tools,
they can make stuff
that's really great.
>>John: Everything I see, almost on a
daily basis, is completely brand new
and I often ask myself,
"How did they do that?"
>>Mark: They'll just do something
that's really off the wall,
that could be disaster,
but it can also end
up being the next massive thing.
>>James: So ultimately, it's
about just removing the
barriers to creativity.
>>Kengo: When you're making
stuff in real life, you know,
there's only so much
you can really do.
What's nice about this is that
you can just keep going really,
and if things go wrong, that's fine.
>>Mark: Empowerment is
a word that we use a lot
when talking about Little Big Planet.
>>Alex: As a kid, I'd
never reached an audience.
I could make my Lego model and
I could never show it to anyone.
But now, you know, the generation
younger than me is capable
of reaching millions of people.
>>Mark: The realization that
you've got the ability to kind
of change your world around
you and make things happen.
>>Kareem: It doesn't
make you sit on the sofa
and watch it, or interact with it.
It actually takes you inside it
and makes you contribute to it.
It changes the console from
being an entertainment device
to an expressive tool.
>>Mark: If you can give
somebody tools that make it feel
like you're playing a game
or that you're having fun,
then the learning is
almost accidental.
>>Alex: These days,
that's the future.